[Music]
October is always a particularly busy
period in Brussels and this year is no
different
all of the EU leaders are currently
arriving here for the European Council
meeting with brexit internal and
cybersecurity climate change a migration
of all on the agenda so we thought we'd
give you a behind-the-scenes look at all
of the action from day one let's take a
look at the red carpet the topic of
discussion for day one is of course
brexit and once each of the 27 EU
leaders have passed along this red
carpet they will be briefed on the state
of play of negotiations by both Theresa
May and Michel Barnier so while those
discussions are happening what goes on
elsewhere it's not just the politicians
who are working cards at the European
Council as well as civil servants and
security staff journalists descend on
Brussels in their thousands to cover the
meeting and attend the plethora of press
conferences which follow the biggest
headlines in the world are being written
in this room right now
speaking of press conferences here we
are outside the national press briefing
of France where Emmanuel macron is
currently addressing the media and
giving his thoughts following the
conclusion of the European Council
meeting national press conferences allow
leaders the opportunity to talk to their
media and also gives journalists the
opportunity to grill their leaders on
some serious subject matters so now it's
after 11:00 p.m. and that is the end of
the European Council for today
more information is available on our
website Concilium dr. Alberto see you
and our social media channels so keep
your eyes peeled and see you next time